this one guy came forward and obviously
looked at me because I was the smallest
and the youngest clearly and came
running towards me to hit me and the one
thing you do learn in all of this is
that you never go down
whatever you do you go down and you are
absolutely completely and utterly
[Music]
hello and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives the podcast from
blood Bible
today we're joined by James Bannon
thanks for coming in James no worries
for anyone who doesn't know who you are
would you mind giving us a brief
introduction yes I'm James Banner I'm
probably best I'm best known as
um being an undercover police officer
infiltrating mobile football Hooligans
between 1987 to 1989. so let's start
right at the start how do you get into
undercover work
I mean I got for me I got selected
um I'd been quite lucky I got mentored
really young as a young police officer
by a really good Sergeant what sort of
age is this uh so I was 18 I was 19. wow
so I just come out of our training
school uh he saw something in me within
sort of six weeks I was on the area car
which is the big fast car that drives
around in plane closers and observer
jumping out and doing various bits and
pieces
um and then within 18 months I was in
playing clothes working on a crime Squad
got special dispensation to do that what
does that mean specialist uh well
normally probationary police officers
aren't allowed to work in plane clothes
for a select period of time or for it
certainly for a long time so I was
working full-time in play clothes at 18
months on a crime Squad well so he
really did so he did yeah he did that
was I just think he saw something in me
and
um he took that and harnessed it and I
got you know I got elevated and was
working on on state within a year I was
living in a squat but at that age is
that the usual age no yes this is really
unusual yeah no it is
um but it was you know if you think
about it it's quite a screwed move
really it's because you wouldn't expect
somebody at 19 20 years old to be doing
that sure so actually it played to our
advantage a little bit when you look
back now and you say he saw something in
you what do you think that was like what
what did what ability do you think he
saw I think he just could say that I was
pretty arrogant and
um pretty confident right uh I knew my
student knew my stuff
um and with an arrogance and confidence
comes you know a bit of bravery and
stuff and um I was and I think there is
is that front of your head's not really
sort of developed to that age properly
and uh you know you do under the age of
like 25 tend to do all the all the crazy
loony stuff because your head's not
quite understanding that actually this
could go seriously wrong and I think
there was a bit of that going on too
that makes sense so you you get put in a
squat uh as at that point are you called
an undercover officer no I was just
called a plane clothes officer then I
was living in that school I lived in
that squat for for three months and when
you say you lived in it as in like you
24 7 no right I don't know so start
eight o'clock and finish at sort of six
or seven and go home it was it was yeah
it was a bit weird but it worked I mean
we were just we were dealing with
situations on an estate at that time
there was there was some big problems so
uh it was mainly stolen so we would buy
a lot of stolen gear back so at that
point was it kind of drugs is that what
you were there was it was there was not
so much but there were some drugs but it
was mainly stolen property at that point
okay at that time so we were dealing
with fencing okay understood I mean that
sounds frightening and the thought of
doing it as a 19 year old sounds even
more frightening
um was that something you fell or no
it's just a job
and um for me and it was um and it just
it's like like everything is just it was
just layers and layers and layers so it
becomes you just become immune to it
they just and you start you have your
tricks and you you know the way that
you're going to get out of stuff and and
as a result of that it then
rolled on and then moved on to working
in a in a fully covert environment at
21. so that was was that kind of like a
almost like a trial phase where they
were seeing how good you were at it I
think it was just it was just something
that we chose to do at that time because
we needed to try and sort it it was the
guy that I was working with my mentor
ran the squad and um we chose to do that
so that's what we did and so you when
you were in the in the squat when you're
on that job
um were the people you were dealing with
on a daily basis did you see them as
dangerous individuals or were you not
afraid of them they were just people
that were desperate and
okay and effectively were doing what
they did in order to survive right I see
the majority I see not all but the
majority so they weren't it wasn't
necessarily a point then when you felt
like you're in danger from the people
you were all of it's dangerous right
it's just there's our various elements
of how dangerous it gets so that you
would like but it could you know at any
minute at any moment it can turn and it
can go horribly wrong so you're always
on you've always got
a part of you that's looking from the
outside looking in as to how you're
going to deal with something should it
go wrong there is always that element
but do you become more relaxed do you
become yes you do you can't just because
of human nature it's just the way that
you are you become used to it and so
therefore you become a bit more blase
but that but you can never lose sight of
the fact that ultimately where you're at
is it can go horribly wrong there any
minute
and what does it look like can you tell
us a bit about
how you invent a cover story like do
they give you it is it a sheet you have
to learn
they should right I mean if we jump onto
the to the to the football sure is
um we were given nothing
absolutely nothing
what's so you're told okay the job in
the squat's done that was great let's
not finished I then went on the crime
Squad right I then went on the crime
Squad and was just working the local
area dealing with crime uh ability in
plain clothes
I then got
a phone call went to Scotland Yard got
interviewed got told on the Monday that
I was going on to a covert Squad
infiltrating football Hooligans did you
feel any anxiety around that no
okay turned up at broccoli police
station and they gave us an office in in
the police station
um above the above the front desk right
and uh which is three miles from at that
point at the Den then as it was Mill was
ground
um and just told to get on with it
so to someone on the outside of that
that sounds
a bit strange that you would be for
somebody from the inside that was a bit
I guess of that from the outside is just
just
unbelievable really when you think about
it but it was just you know it wasn't
really thought out it wasn't
particularly well managed
um and we were just totally gone with it
and was that is that because that kind
of
football hooligan undercover football
hooligan work was new and there wasn't
process for it always at just the way it
worked
they just didn't take it seriously right
they didn't really understand the you
know the concepts of what we would what
we were trying to do yeah and we would
you know there was there was lots of
great ideas but it was just a complete
and utter mismanagement completely
um and you know they're asking people to
go out to a football club in into a
um to a group of people uh mainly where
all men
um who've known each other really pretty
much all their lives and just turn up
and it's like hi I'm Jim from Wandsworth
and uh and you've never seen me before
you don't know who I am but you know I'm
a Milwaukee supporter and let me in your
gang and uh
I haven't got anything to back it up
yeah effectively how it how it started
well let's yeah so you said a second ago
so
what was the cover Story how are you
given a cover Story how do you create
your Legend yeah um is you you create
yourself
and so that's what I did
and I realized very very quickly that we
weren't going to get any help or
assistance so we were going to need to
do it ourselves
so I had for me the only thing I had I
had a business card
which my my cover which was Jim fold
Spectrum decorating with an address that
was an accommodation address in Croydon
so they'd given you that no no no you've
made that yes I got that made up right
but that's all I had so it's a hi I'm
Jim from Wandsworth and I'm thinking
here's my business card that was it
okay and when you when you
God because it sounds it sounds a little
bit yes
yeah yeah sure but so how like when they
interviewed you for it did you know it
was going to be that last like did they
say oh look you're gonna go in figure it
all out yourself you're 20. we were told
this is what we're looking to do it's
going to be a short-term operation you
have to go in you're to infiltrate more
football against get evidence from
conspiracy to Riot etc etc uh and then
we'll rest all the nasty people at the
end of it and you'll go to court and
they'll go to prison right and why was
millwall targeted well it was every
football club there was there were a
number yeah right there were a number of
clubs Nationwide and it was a political
move right can you tell us a bit more
about that well because it's um because
of the um
it's Margaret Thatcher
um there was the famous millwall Luton
Wright
and as a result of that
um she decided that she wanted to stamp
it out uh and one of the ways that they
chose to do that was by which is the
same as as it's now come out with the
miners is they were using people to
infiltrate in order to get evidence uh
in order to be one step ahead of
everybody
um and so the political decision was is
that we'd use or they would use covert
police officers in order to gain the
evidence in order to arrest people were
you aware of which of the clubs were
being targeted we were yeah we were yeah
so do you know yeah so man city leads
Arsenal Chelsea West Ham
okay interesting and what do you think
were they the ones that were seen as the
particularly problematic ones I do think
it was random no no it were the ones
that were considered to be
problematic okay and those that had that
reputation okay and that hooligan
element right okay so were you were like
were you a football fan at that time
were you aware of really not really so
again that seems surprising to me
because I knew it I'd been I'd policed
it you know right early on
uh
um and I'd been when I was a kid to
children with my dad and my granddad but
it was really you know it was it wasn't
something that that attracted me you
know I'd been and watched it and
um but you know I I I'm been involved in
hooliganism or you know in that
traveling away or any of that sort of
stuff so so in preparation for
introducing yourself to people at Milt
world did you have to do a load of
research on the club I did yeah tons of
research right and sadly the guy I
worked with did none
oh God right were you aware of that as
you went into the situation yeah the
first night was the biggest disaster in
the history of the world okay let's
let's go on to that so we went out the
first night went into a millwall pub
no cover yeah this really
frustrating
ability to stare at people and was
they're in there was not a great thing
in a pub particularly in one that you've
never been in before and he started
staring at someone and I went to the
toilet and came back and he was
surrounded and oh God they started
questioning us and he came out with and
this is absolutely 100 percent
true is we came out with a line that he
thought that John fashion it was white
oh
from that you don't
we've got absolutely smashed not beaten
up did you properly yeah first night out
oh my God he thinks that John fashion is
white and we get the absolute granny
kicked out of us yeah God
so okay so that point how come the whole
operation isn't well then then he
realized that he needed to do some
work yeah but how would you
possibly make get back in with the club
if they've if the loaded he was so
stupid right and he was such a stupid
thing to say and do that um he got away
with it yeah I can see that because you
wouldn't think it actually perversely
actually really helped right yes you
would not think that anyone was trying
to integrate with a football club would
say that so yes I can see it just was
not on not on his game he got better
okay so you see you get you go at the
first night
say that one of the most famous of the
time black footballers is white yeah get
beaten up and then how does it progress
from there next day next day leads away
okay get there early on the football
special and there's nothing special
about a football special I can assure
you right we're going up it's our first
away game and then we get the infamous
no one likes us coming up the stairs and
as they come up the stairs it's the guys
that beat us up in the pub the night
before
and how did that go I just confronted
him we had no it wasn't there was no
there was no other option we were gonna
have to it was that was our moment that
was either we were gonna completely and
utterly fail or we were gonna have to
take it head-on which is what we did so
what did you what did you do I just went
up to him and said you know what was
last night all about Etc
um and then they started talking about
and I just said like ain't my fault he's
married to my sister and the guy went oh
I'm married to the sister hang on we've
all got one of those right right okay I
understand and then we got on the train
met up with the guys that we then
ultimately spent the next two and a half
years with and at that point it was the
beginnings of yeah working into the
group
actually one bit I just want to pick up
just for people who might not know is
you said when you came up at the stadium
you heard the chant no one likes us can
you just explain what that was
so no that's meals Anthem so no one
likes us we don't care and why why do
you think that is so Random or because
no one likes them very much and they
don't really give a okay
okay so that that's why okay if well it
makes sense do you think anyone could
train themselves to do that or do you
think there's something yeah so what is
it that gives you the ability to
confront a group of people that beat you
up the night before knowing that you
were exactly the sort of person they'd
want to beat up
um
arrogance
um an ability to try and do the best
that you can in the job with what you've
got and so therefore Pride
not wanting to not succeed
um and
wanting to have that ability to see
whether or not you can get yourself out
of that situation
um it's it's a it's a really difficult
thing to explain people if it's not a
quality that you've got you know the
quality that you've got or that you that
you want to use
um it's not
recommended
it's not a career route or career path
that you would go here you should do
that but I mean it's an amazing thing to
to be asked to do it at 20 years old you
know 99.9 of other police officers will
never get the opportunity to do so did
you feel like a lot of trust had been
you've been given a lot of trust to make
this succeed and you know they yes in a
way but ultimately also it was you know
it's a massive career move so we offered
that at 20 years old you know and how
long did you think that job would be at
the time six months six months that's
what you were told and then the other
quality I suppose that comes with it is
some people are better at lying some
people are worser lying yeah but if
you're inventing an entire personality
uh backstory everything and then you're
putting that on while you interact with
people and the mistake is could be
disastrous
is that something you can train to do or
is that just something that's in you to
be able to
present a different truth like that I
think to do it well is something that
you have that just has to be there it's
not um I mean obviously you get tricks
and
um now it's a completely different
scenario now is there are
um you know you get your back cover you
get your backstories you can do all the
social media interview you know and do
all that stuff and create this this
Fantastical person that doesn't that
isn't true but you can make it online to
make it look like it is we don't have
any of that back then so it was just
your wits and effectively being able to
convince people that you're something
that you're not but I suppose that's
interesting isn't it because the social
media can help because you can set up a
backstory but I guess back then social
media not existing might have been
better because people can't look up and
go hang on this guy's in that photo or
he's friends with this question and then
you've got you know there's no mobile
phones and it was um no email no you
know sort of little limited on that
style back in you know sort of 87 we had
pages and that was about as good as it
got right and we didn't get those until
sort of four or five months in and was
was was undercover work at that point
and known thing like with the Hooligans
that you were spending time with would
they have been suspicious of people yeah
because they've been they'd been on
operation previously right where and a
loads of people have just been arrested
we managed to slip in just as they'd
been arrested so it looked like we were
sort of we
we didn't come to it late we came in
they and got arrested and we were all
already sort of in
um because they were picking people off
as whilst we were still there but
and they've done the same at West Ham
and they've done the same at Chelsea
and what are you feeling about the
people at this point like in your head
are you just indifferent are you just
like this is a job are you thinking
you're a scum like I'm gonna take you
out it's better for society if you're in
prison like what what's your feeling
behind the scenes towards the people so
our job was to take nasty horrible
people who want to pick people up for
the sake of it
um
out of circulation and send them to
prison
the majority of the people that I came
across were really nice guys um
but they were an element that weren't
very nice
and so the way that I looked at it was
I'm going to make sure that the really
nasty horrible people
get
they come up and get put away for what
they're doing um
sadly sad thing about that is there will
be other people on the fringes that get
dragged into that because that's just
how it is but the majority so the
majority of the people that I
infiltrated or I worked with or you know
in relation to or against her you want
to look at it
um we're really nice guys and I had a
lot of time for them they were just nice
people it was hard workings
not really no but
they were an element of people that
weren't very nice it's just a bit like
everything in life isn't it there's
people you work with that most of them
were right but there's the odd
um and it's the same with school you're
at school and it's like the most most of
the people you're at school with Roy but
then there's the
you know there's there's a collection of
knobs so and it's just a bit like
it was a bit like that a microcosm of
any other part of society and so what
you do is you then just make sure that
you focus your time but sadly you then
have to focus your time on the people
that aren't very nice you don't really
want to spend time with but have to
because you have to gain the evidence
and was any of that some did you start
to I mean we might get onto it later but
did you start to feel any guilt around
that with the people that you thought
were nice or was it still just this is a
job it's a job yeah and I know it's
bizarre
but it's that's the only way you can
deal with stuff like that it was my job
my job was to be as convincing as I
could be get as much evidence as I could
the operation would then conclude and I
would then move on so how do you then
move from the periods where you're kind
of like trying to introduce yourself to
different groups of people and and get
involved how do you get further in into
integrated into that group and how do
you sort of make your way into the Inner
Circle it just takes time and what we
did was there was a real millwall Pub
and we started going there in there at
lunch times when they weren't frequented
by
they were just threatened by local
people so we started going into the pub
at lunchtime and we did that for three
months
so when we turned up for the next season
um because we started in the March so we
had a little bit of a little bit of the
football and then we finished and we had
the summer and then we did a bit bits
and pieces and then all the research and
all the bits that we needed but we
certainly needed he needed to do anyway
the sergeant we got to September when we
walked into the pub for the first game
all the bar mates knew us right because
we walked in rgmou is really really good
to see you at zone so what do you want
your usual and all that stuff instantly
you've got on a level of acceptance so
it's then once you've got that you've
taken those steps then it makes it makes
the the process moving forward a bit
easier still not
you know
um simple but it makes that process a
bit easier and then is it a case of
just starting to chat to people in the
pub and just say oh you know just
starting that yeah the landlord was a
real top was one of Mills top top guys
right and a really nice bloke right uh
and he had some problems with someone
outside with Nikki's garden furniture
and we I got lucky I was I ran out with
him you know we sold it out we got the
garden furniture back and I sort of
got accepted on that level got you
um so we were a bit lucky on that front
how does it work with like say you'd run
out there caught the guy and the
landlord had started to beat him up and
you're undercover and you're thinking
yeah how does that like what level can
you go to to protect your cover
you go to whatever you have to go to in
order for that to for that to you know
for you to do your job I mean there's
there's levels but ultimately it's a
it's really really really fine line and
again it's it's a real head because your
head is going
you've got am I going to get beaten up
is it if I do I need to get involved
because if I don't get involved is he
then gonna think why are you not getting
involved do I not want to get you know
if he gets too involved if he hurts the
guy am I then going to put myself in a
position where it's just you've got all
that going on milliseconds making those
decisions
and when you say it it
I presume it's not written down anywhere
so it's up to you eventually to justify
it like if you had to you can justify
anything right in relation to what
you're doing
what would be my argument it's about and
about justification is well if I've done
that I would and that's the sort of the
problem and certainly what's come out
with
certain other operations that have gone
on
um over time is about you know is it
morally right is it you know how far do
you go what are your levels is you know
you just have to you just have to take a
view and then and make a decision at
that time as to
you know
what do I do
like the famous one for me was the
Crystal Palace guy on the train come
come here about that beaten up so we're
with a guy and completely just
had I known eight months further if we
were in eight months 12 months
um further on into the into the
operation then my reaction would have
been would have been different but we
would it was relatively early on so we
have a guy he was sitting there was a
guy with a Crystal Palace badge on
sitting with his wife and his two kids
and we were with this guy that we we
just met he was
um being vocal about wanting to go to
London Bridge and have a fight and all
the stuff so we went with him and he
just attacked the guy on the train he
was sitting with his family he was
sitting with his family a lot and I mean
punched him kicked him kicked got him on
the floor
I mean
completely uh
unprovoked completely unnecessary
um
and you're watching this and in front of
this guy doing that in front of his kids
which is
you know and then as you get further I
got further on into the operation that
would no one would ever do that it's
just because the guy was a yeah
and what what he should have done he's
jumped on him and and given him a slap
too I said what are you doing because
it's just not what it's not you know it
doesn't work like that right right and
um but we were early on and so right so
so if you'd known how it worked it would
have been if I'd be further on in right
and I'd have had more you know I I you
know I I knew more about what I was
doing but yeah you know I had I was more
confident and I was more aware and I had
you know I was with then that situation
would have been dealt with completely
differently so what so so the guy
wearing the Press Crystal Palace jumper
with his kids he got beaten up and then
what he just sat there on the train
beating up with his well he sat the
crime with his wife and his two kids it
was
horrenda of all of the things in the
whole of the operation it was the worst
day
because you feel so useless and you know
so all you could so I just jumped up and
started singing no one likes us to try
and it worked and he stopped to join in
singing with you
and it's the look from the kids and the
wife and
you know this poor man I've been just
just you know that's minding his own
business going to London with his kids
he's just been brutally attacked by this
guy and no one no one called the police
or stopped the train or no one does mate
yeah and no one could call the police he
wasn't the time with mobile phones or no
one would record it and then put it on
them this is the only one know this guy
it wasn't about any of that yeah so that
all we could hope was that he would
report it
we knew who he was
so we have a crime and then over time he
would then be arrested for it right but
the guy never reported it and you can't
log that as something that happens so
when the operation wraps we did right
okay we did but we need a victim okay I
see right and we didn't have one
wow that must have been
yeah I can see why that was a hard moral
it was absolutely horrendous yeah you
know and there are days that you pick
out where you know you know that that
you'll never forget you know there are a
number of situations and uh and
circumstances on the day that you just
go right
you know and there's there's three or
four of those when you just think back
and you go
right
ones that stay with you yeah
were there any situations like that but
where you felt in danger
ask Norway
when we ended up in the north Bank it
was an FA Cup game and I ended up just
with a group of
hard and Mill were in the in the Arsenal
North Bank okay so for anyone who
doesn't quite get what that means
um that means going in hybrid as it was
then so it's not now the Emirates but it
was the high it was hybrid that's the
Arsenal stadium so the Arsenal Stadium
Highbury in the in their in the home
ends of the Arsenal home end
um and where the away supporters and
there was 15 of us in the Arsenal North
how did you end up there
just the landlord from the pub and
15 other guys that were 14 other guys
that were with him and we ended up
did they want to be there oh yeah yeah
so that was I didn't want to renovate
there to be fair but we had the
situation where they're going like come
with us what are you going to do
so what they just want to go to I just
went in we stood in stood in the Arsenal
Northbound surrounded by 8 000 Arsenal
and they then start singing no one likes
us oh God
and then what happened well the sergeant
by that stage had off from the
from the from the operation or from that
day from from that from that situation
right he just was up the top and just
went
which is wise yeah ain't got them they
started singing no one likes us and
you're in the middle of it thinking I'm
gonna die
and they were big grown men in their 30s
and 40s I was 20 year old guy in a pair
of dungarees
printing right okay
standing there
so what happened
it went really quiet
and then the sort of crowd moved out
and there was as we were singing
and then we stopped
and then this one guy came forward and
obviously
looked at me because I was the smallest
and the youngest clearly and came
running towards me to hit me
and then the landlord just took one step
in front of me and just went
I think this gazer straight on the nose
so hard that he almost did this
somersault and landed and clattered onto
the concrete Terrace
and it was so bad that all of them are
well and all of the Arsenal went
as he hit the ground and then these like
two little guys came out from nowhere
it was like sort of I suppose that's
before it was a bit like Bene just
grabbed him by the ankles and the crowd
opened up and they dragged him in and
then the crowd closed and then everyone
just piled in
and then it was just a fight it was just
getting free for all
and the one thing you do learn in all of
this is that you never go down right
whatever you do you go down and you are
absolutely completely and utterly
so you just got that you just I was just
windmills
and ended up
spilling out onto the pitch got nicked
and then
and there's because at that stage there
were like two sort of people that police
football there were the cake I used to
call the people that drive a desk and
eat cake in the week and then do
football on Saturday for overtime and
then there was the
tactical support group who were
affectionately known as the thick and
stupid group
who would have Shields and things just
were up for a fight so that's not a
great mix you got a fat bloke who
doesn't really want to be there who's
getting overtime and wants to eat cake
and then you've got a lot of other guys
running around with shields who just
want to beat the out of everyone
so fortunately I got Nick by the cake
and he took me the wrong way around the
ground instead of going that way he went
that way and took me towards 10 000 mil
right okay and I managed to break free
and run and dive in the crowd so when
they just tuck you in that was it and
then mine was sort of from that moment
it was for me I was sort of I was in
really yeah because presumably they see
that and go legend yeah
God so did the guys that you'd been on
the other side with did anyone get fired
did anyone get badly beaten up or was it
not really yeah okay never saw never saw
most of them ever again right it's okay
and was that how it was you'd turn up to
these matches and there'd just be groups
of random men that you'd never that one
right I'd never seen obviously I knew
the landlord but I hadn't seen some of
the other guys okay I never saw him
again so it's interesting because you
said earlier that the London was a great
guy and really nice but then at the same
time he's someone that seems to have
like a predisposition for enjoying quite
extreme violence
yeah but it was Arsenal away on it
sure but he he'd actively gone and yeah
yeah but you could could you reconcile
that at that point with someone that you
go oh he's a good guy he just loves
battering people no he would have got
nicked right
okay but he didn't but he would have
done okay
all right so
um that sounds like you've done a pretty
good job of
sort of ingratiating yourself with the
with them were there any points where
you came close to getting exposed
so we had one day where again sergeant
and I'd worked with were told and that
we'd been working on a on a house
um because we our cover was painters and
decorations yeah giving them the address
because he was pissed
and they come down to see us and
obviously there were people there
working on the roof and we weren't there
right
and they said I don't know what you're
talking about oh so we got confronted in
the pub
this is further into it this was about
eight months in oh wow okay who the
are you which is a fair question yeah
and there was still so there was still
even eight months in and after all this
stuff there was oh they were they were
they would they were questioning
everyone right everyone was getting
questioned not just to everyone and
I was questioning anyone yeah right okay
yeah that's the best scenario isn't it
it's just it's just you question
everyone too so you press that Double
Bluff who left for you I've never seen
you here before yeah and how did you get
out of that well they said to me yeah
yeah who are you and I said you know you
know who I am and that was the point
when it was either
we either confess and we run or we've
run up and so I just front it up
and he got very very very close to
becoming quite a physical or location
and
everyone
wanted to believe that we weren't
um
and um
so me and one of the guys and got almost
got to you know he got quite physical
and uh
and then he just went out and I walked
out the pub
and that was the day when I knew then
that we had to I had to do something
that was going to convince someone 100 I
wasn't our bill
but I needed to try and make sure that
it was legal
but I needed to do something
and what did you end up coming up with
we went to another Pub and they started
playing there was this Duke there's this
um computer goal there was game called
Dave Lee Travis's pop black thing right
let's play this thing right where you'd
answer a Red Bull question and it was
one question it was really easy and then
you'd pick either a different color of
the snooker so you'd the easiest
question was yellow the hardest question
was black yeah
so they started playing the game for bit
for drinks and I just got up for my
question that looks at it
looked at it didn't answer it I'll get
the beers went away got the drinks came
back
and I could see everyone looking at me
thinking is he doing and then it came to
me again and there's no word of a lie
the question was who won the World Cup
in 1966
so I'm looking at it looking at it
they're all screaming at me that's right
you know Jim answer me answer we answer
it and then I just grabbed the sergeant
by the throat who had no idea what I was
doing
and I said I can't it's why have you
told him why have you told him why why
you know what you know you've told them
and he's like I don't know what you're
going on about and he didn't know of a
clue what I was going on about
and I just went you know it's not my
fault I can't read or write
and he went I haven't told him I haven't
told them I went outside
ten minutes or five minutes later they
all come out and said oh no we didn't
know honestly you know so I'm so sorry
so you know we didn't know about it I'm
really sorry we didn't mean to put you
in that position
I'm waiting and I'm waiting I'm waiting
for the for it to drop when they
suddenly go and it did and one of them
just turned around and went wow
my God you just yes you accusing me of
being an old bill and he can't even read
or write uh okay which was a brilliant
move for that day but this TS move if
you think about it because I then end up
for 18 months having to make out I can't
read or write right
so which is a lot harder than anything
than it sounds no no I mean it's because
even stuff like going in like when
you're reading train things or you're
going on a train or whatever and you're
saying like what does a ticket say you
have to and they all take the piss so
it's like you're driving and they go
come off here come off in you know it's
the wrong turn off
and you come off and it's like ah what
are you doing coming off here can't you
read and all right okay was it the wrong
turn and then then you come back on and
your stuff
what's what's interesting to me about
that is because is that I'd I would have
imagined that if you were going to come
up with such a big thing like that you
would have had to have gone and told
some sort of superior officer and they
would have gone look this is a benefit
to doing it this is the this is the
problems with doing it let's talk it let
me just give you an example of what
you're dealing with in with senior
police officers at that time okay
we had a massive meeting at Scotland
Yard in relation to the West Ham game
okay which is millwall West Ham there's
always a bit is one of the biggest games
in relation to
um potential for violence because they
hate each other
so we go
the sergeant goes and gives this
presentation and then at the close of it
says you know we we'd be doing really
well and you know Jim's done this great
thing and he's you know he's you know
you can't you can't even meet the fact
that you can't you can't read or write
at one of the senior officers stops in
midflow and goes
what do you mean he can't read or write
he said well yeah you can't he can't
read or write and he said
if you can't read it right how on Earth
did he get through training school
and you're like
no I can read or write it's part of my
coverage of course I can read and write
oh right for a minute I thought we had
an illiterate policeman and you're like
and there's a thought
right so and that is genuinely the
level of incompetence and people
you were dealing with and I suppose the
lack of understanding about what you
were doing totally and you just come out
and go right
no wonder we're walking around with a
business card
and when you when you when you're
getting further involved like this and
you're making up these extended cover
stories is the fact that you're based
three miles away is that becoming more
and more we changed all that you changed
it see we got we got looked after by an
unbelievably
brilliant police officer right he was
working for greater Manchester police at
the time he was running a covert team
for them
what's he sort of took over and said
this is he just went
how I know for you surviving you need
this this this this this got us
everything okay okay great and
embarrassed the Metron please
embarrass them into helping us so if you
don't do this I will and then then they
started to take us seriously
as you're progressing like that
does it start to take a mental toll like
basically lying every day to people that
you're spending extended periods of time
with because you said earlier that a lot
of them are nice people and people that
you thought were just hard working it's
not easy yeah
but no job is you know it's not easy
it's just it's
but it's you just get used to it it does
you know it's like people go oh you know
you know when were you when did you feel
the most scared or when was it most it's
dangerous the entire time because you
could speak you can be in a supermarket
with your Missy shopping and bump into
someone
so you just you're forever always
you know you'd never I'd never ever sit
in a restaurant and I can't now I never
seen everyone my mates and family will
laugh about the fact that I can't sit
with my back to the door I have to sit
in the restaurant at the back of the
restaurant so I can see everything that
everything that's going on everyone who
comes in everyone even now it's just
because it's just become part and parcel
and it's now you know it's now become
amusing but it's um but it is what it is
I'm not good at it and because of that
it's because I need to be at that point
I needed to be careful I needed to be
aware of my surroundings so that and
that is one of I suppose one of the
drawbacks or
disadvantages of doing stuff like that
is that's that's difficult to break that
cycle did you live in London at that
time yeah so we did a piece before with
another uh Undercover
cop but he was a Narcotics officer yeah
so he was from London but he was doing
Manchester or Birmingham
is that was that normal that you would
be living near where you were doing your
undercover it's not it's not ideal but
again back then it was it's just you
know it is what it is
um you know I came from Wandsworth
obviously that time I was living in West
Norwood
and then I moved out to the country
and we use how are your personal
relationships like can you can you tell
people that are close to you what you're
doing or does it have to be a secret
forever not really they tend to you
suddenly go from being
12 stone and relatively fit to 15 stone
with long air and and not overly fit and
overweight because
drinking and eating takeaway food and
stuff takes its toll
and so did you have a partner at the
time I did and would they ever say you
know what's going on has ever seen you
yeah she okay right yeah she knew it
must have been sort of a frightening for
her
yeah I think she just it was just it's
who you were
yeah it was just you know I tried not to
bring it home it's difficult but I tried
not to yeah but it was but you do
you know I'd
you'd be lying if you turn around and
said it it was you know it was it's all
it was all lazy and plain sighted and it
was then it was obviously I didn't had
its moments and what about your mates
like your best mates did you could you
tell them or
um
did I tell my I don't really have much
to do with it was I didn't want to put
them in that position yeah because my
best mates weren't police officers all
my best mates were people I grew up with
on a an estate in South London he were
all
doing their own thing right okay
um
some of which were was legal most of it
which wasn't
most of my mates I think most of the
mates I grew up with I think
certainly 50 of them went to prison wow
so you just kept all that separate what
you did yeah because it wasn't fair on
them yeah okay that makes sense
Okay so
let's talk about how that operation
started to come to an end
we had
the Chelsea trial collapsed the West Ham
trial collapsed
the millwall trial they got people got
sent to prison
and then
um laterally they that they appealed and
they also got released oh wow how long
was it that that all got wrapped up so
that was happening whilst we were
working the Chelsea the Headhunter trial
and the and the West Ham trial
um both collapsed because you'd be you'd
expected it to last six months hadn't
you initially and how long was it so we
were two years we were two and a half
years the operation lasted wow so we
were just over
just about just over two years in when
it all started to go wrong okay for the
previous trials yeah and the Chelsea
trial and the west down trial
um collapsed quite rightly because the
police officers lied they made it up
because because they hadn't managed to
do their job so they made it up oh no no
and they got found out
you know they've got they've got people
that are being involved in
disturbances and fights and stuff
they've got video footage of them at a
wedding
you know they couldn't have been at the
football because there's a video of them
so then you then put into question all
the other evidence and it then started
to just unravel and it just fell fell
apart
and so both those trials collapsed and
then it started to become about not
losing face
and again it was a from what we
understand a political decision when
they just went there need to stop
said right so they didn't even bring it
to try but this so what happened to the
body of the phone call Mate we were
sitting in the office yeah we were going
we were going on an away match on a
Saturday we got a phone call on the
Tuesday
saying
to the sergeant and he went answered the
phone he went right okay well all right
fine I'll let everyone know put the
phone down he went we're done we're
finished operations concluded
after two and a half years yep I mean
how did that feel appreciate
like disappointed angry sad what was the
all of those yeah
um I think at the time I remember at the
time that my main cons um
annoyance was the fact that millwall
were actually in the first Division and
doing quite well and we weren't going to
go and get to watch much with any more
of the games that season I was one one
of my First Reactions
um
yeah and then they decided that no one
was going to be arrested
oh they weren't even in a try and act on
it it was just
concluded that overnight done but how
could they justify that the money that
has got on the the whole operation
awesome
so no explanation just it's over we're
not arresting anyone get out you're not
to go back to millwall year to have
you're not going back to millwall you're
to have two weeks off and then and then
for me you ought to go back to orbington
and drive a panda car
okay hang on so two and a half years of
your life has gone into this and they
just say you you that's you you don't go
back ever again yeah and you're going
back just to a regular to open sense to
drive a panel
to anyone who doesn't know what that is
a panda car is a police car in the UK
but so
so how do you like so so was that was
that it or did you extract yourself
somehow did you make up a cover story
for leaving did you say like it might
sense wouldn't it was it it's done
she just never went back
that was it
did that not feel like in a weird way at
that point like a big part of your life
had just been
lost like the the people he was seeing
every day what he did is it made me
realize at that point that I need to be
in control of my own destiny and that I
need to put myself in a position where
no one is ever going to make a decision
about what I'm doing
that I cannot be in control of that's
what that did
where I went right
learn from this
I'm 23 years old
I'm going to make sure that I never put
myself in a position where somebody is
going to be able to tell me that I can't
do something or that I'm going to be
stopped from doing something
because of the fact that they haven't
got the to push on for on with
it or somebody else somewhere or
somewhere has decided that we're not
going to do that anymore
so I guess you didn't drive that Panda
car
I left that was it that I was
done six weeks and I was out
which was out of all of the decisions
about working undercover and doing all
the bits and pieces
was the bravest decision of the lot for
me because it's all I'd known since I
was
18 and a half
I've got to what I considered to be an
elite
officer doing stuff that the majority of
other people will never get to do
for it all to be concluded on a phone
call
and at that point were you seen as an
elite officer or was the whole thing
seen as a slightly embarrassing let's
not talk about it anymore yeah that's
how it was saying right so did you feel
quite betrayed by the force at that
point I would think we all did to be
fair yeah although the other three guys
all stayed in
just got repositioned in different areas
yep well the sergeant went back to
lewisham
as a death Sergeant which is one mile
away from Mills football ground
and did anyone ever get in any yeah they
did so one of the guys got next and came
in and he was there in uniform to charge
him
and um
came in and went
what are you doing here well
I'm really sorry I'm a I'm a policeman
and the he looked at him and went
so I wouldn't want to be you when Jim
finds out does he still believed that I
was
Jim from Wandsworth he couldn't read or
write even though he was looking at the
guy that I did it with
and uh
as I said there was a policeman in
uniform yeah do you think they all
eventually found out I did all find out
who you were yeah they did how do you
think they would have processed that
um
I met one of them because I was doing a
film for channel four and I went because
because again
I thought they wouldn't recognize me
because I'd lost so much weight and was
I went back there with I was doing a
film with um for channel four and I went
back with a couple of the actors
and I
bumped into one of them
and the two actors absolutely
themselves because they just because
they knew what I'd done and then all of
a sudden one of the guys and he just
went what are you doing here you want
Brave pills or what and I just went well
and the guy I was with it was quite a
famous actor just went oh no no no no
we're acting we're acting right you know
we're just he's doing he's an actor yeah
we know who he is mate
said I've been watching you because I
became an actor and you know said we've
seen you in doing stuff from
we saw your episode of the bill when we
did this but we don't really think you
should come back here anymore because
some people won't be quite so pleasant
if they see you um
do you still at that point you know when
we talked about you as a younger person
sort of having
not feeling the fear that I think a lot
of people would have felt as a slightly
more mature person going back to that
situation and being confronted was it
the same deal or are you are you in a
place now where you would think oh
I've been I've been World War a few
times
um
yeah it's just you know no one got
nicked
it was a job no one got arrested
nobody got sent to prison
I was just doing my job
some people have a problem with that
uh which these which is there right
um
you know I met I've met with a few of
the guys I did a one-man show based on
based on I wrote a book about what I did
um and then did a one-man show on that
which was really successful and did
really really well and a couple of the
guys or few of the guys that were
involved came and saw it and I saw I
chats with them afterwards the landlord
you ever seen him since no
no how do you think he'd feel
I don't know
apparently somebody said he was
he found it highly amusing
that he I'd managed to get away with
that
and then they didn't have a desire to
sort of seek me out no no you're not
you're not following each other on
Twitter or anything but I'm aware of no
see the
if you're walking down the street and
you saw him just the two of you walking
to facing each other would you turn
around and go down a side street or
would you be like boom all right you
know how would you feel about bumping
into people from that wouldn't have a
problem with that I haven't got a
problem with bumping into people I've
got I don't
you know I've got no shame about what I
did
you know I'm um
you know I've not got a
yeah there's there's
a lot of people you know that you know
that would have a problem with it if you
want to put it in their face but I never
would not look to do that you know I'm
happy to have a conversation with anyone
about it it's just you know it's what it
was a job it's what I did I was I was 21
years old
so I so ID was a film that Moraine said
it was made about your about this
operation yeah and and how did that come
about as something people were aware of
because presumably if the at the time if
the police were kind of trying to just
cover it over a little bit how did that
end up becoming a script a film script
so I was doing a play I was doing a
um
second season so I was doing uh
uh Sarah Kane it was a famous playwright
sadly's not here anymore
um I was doing a collection of her work
she was directing me in some work and
her partner at the time was a
um was a guy who's a writer
and
um he had a conversation with me about
writing down my story and said you
should write it down
so I went back and wrote it
gave it to him which was the original
story and then he wrote based on the
original story he wrote the treatment
which he gave to a number of film
production companies and everyone wanted
it became a sort of one of those scripts
that within a week everyone was talking
about it and everyone wanted to do it
and um
he then wrote the screenplay and it got
made and Phil Davis directed it he did a
I think did an amazing job with what he
had really
uh that really good job and um
yeah and my idea for writing it was
because I wanted the point in it because
I wanted to be an act you know I was an
actor at the time and that's what I
wanted to do
and that was my drive was because I just
wanted some work
and I got a part in it
and um and then the day before they
started filming they
told me I couldn't be in it all right
um because everyone was portraying the
film as a piece of fiction I didn't want
anyone to know that it was true okay uh
because at that time they were nervous
about what the match what about what the
police would do right how they would
whether they would accept it or not
close it down so they made out that he
wasn't drunk even though it was parts of
it were factually correct a large part
of it certainly the drive of the story
so I ended up with
the film being made nobody really know
him it was about me and
not being able to be in it um
disappointing
yeah hugely
yeah it was yeah because it was you know
it was
when I wanted to play me but it was um
yeah I was naive I suppose in a way
but lots of people like that film it
became like a cult classic didn't it it
has yeah no yes it is it is a you know
lots of people quote lines from it and
know it and and are now aware of the
fact that he is
you know and it's quite a cool thing to
be to have a filmmate about you
by the time you're 30 and you're not
dead or in prison
so I suppose there's you know that's
quite a it's quite a good thing to have
I suppose
it's just that I you know it would have
been the film I made would have made no
there's a you know spoiler alert but it
has been out for like
30 odd years so I don't think it's too
bad to give a spoiler but um
the end of the film sees the main
character basically losing his mind
essentially doesn't it like you can't
it's sort of ambiguous at the end
whether he knows he's undercover still
or if he's completely yeah lost his mind
and and gone into that side of it and
become a football hooligan and now
that's what his identity is
you seem talking to you now you seem
like someone who's got like a very
strong
sense of yourself and so it doesn't seem
like something that would have happened
to you but do you think people in that
position could have been affected in
that kind of a way yeah it's a film
um and
um I can see why they he you know the
guy who wrote the film chose to go that
route I didn't I didn't agree with it at
the time and I don't agree with it now
but then that's because it's I'm just
looking at it from having had a personal
experience but yeah there are people
that a lot of people
that go into that and work work in that
environment who don't come out of it
quite as fortunate as I did
and where does it where do you in terms
of you and your relationship with have
you are you able to watch football
anymore or you know much more into rugby
mate okay and when you look back now
over your life and the experiences you
had and I know that you had a lot of
experiences
post that that job but when you look
back at your life like what's something
you think you've learned like what
what's your life taught you
trust yourself
um don't be afraid of taking a leap or a
chance
and
be mindful of others so
effectively treat people like you want
to be treated yourself
and because there are lots and you can a
lot of people up on the way up
but you're gonna need them when you come
back down because you all everyone will
always come back down at some point
you're going to do something and you're
gonna you're gonna falter and you're
gonna come back
and you want to make sure that all those
people that you've been nice to on the
way up are going to help you get back up
to where you are and I've had that on a
couple of occasions okay look James
you're someone that's had a fascinating
life and I think we could have spent two
or three hours in this conversation but
unfortunately it's come to an end but
thanks so much for coming and sharing
your story pleasure it is incredible and
it's one that I know people be
genuinely interested to listen to thanks
for coming in no worries thanks very
much
a Drug Squad hated it because they they
were very specialist unit you know
trained in surveillance and there were
seasoned detectives and to have people
like me under the under their feet got
on their nerves a lot but
when I was there one of them looked at
me looked me up and down and said um you
fancy having to go up buying some crack
cocaine